the Amish engine focus a lot on on
rulesets and procedural
problems the benefit of that is the
freedom of movement that that enables
for the player way they're advancing the
engine adds for a sort of order of
magnitude increase in the type of things
you can do one of the great features was
while you're in the wingsuit you could
use the crop we cook at the same time so
for us a lot of that complexity comes
from just the natural layer of art
mechanics together I think the biggest
thing that the player will see is being
able to have the freedom to do many
things while still kind of just plain
one of the more frustrating moments in
games is you have this awesome idea in
your head and you just hit the button
and you said the awesome idea should
have happened right there but the game
is in the middle of an animation or it's
decided that you should be doing
something else so we spent a lot of time
a lot of Technology try to get that
feeling where no matter what button you
pressed it would respond in the way you
thought it should respond we have a ton
of new memory we're able to the
processing power the parallel structures
that are in place now it allows for
things that you can do on last gen we'd
started using album destruction which is
an extension for the hammock physics
that deals with things breaking apart
and we've been one of the early adopters
for their latest iteration of this that
system think just about for example what
we call the caves object so those are
the things that you destroy to liberate
a military base in just goes to the
technique which was used
it's called mesh swapping so you did a
certain amount of damage and then a bit
of illusion is man and you swap what you
see for another visual now everything is
procedural meaning that each one of
these objects is composed by sub objects
and then they are attached together as
they would be in real world so what we
use now it's an inner system based on
behavior of trees rather than on goal
that behavior it means that our
designers are a much are much much more
in control of what they eye actually
does the designers have set up ways to
find firing lines when you're in the air
it seems pretty simple as a human but if
you imagine what that calculation is the
math behind it of someone actually
having to find all the certain things
that have to go through these behavior
trees so that the AI is making the right
decision just the ability to create
worlds of this density from complexity
and size that alone is something that
makes the avalanche engine stand out in
front of many other engines
you